russia has widened the scope of its war
on ukraine a suspected cruise missile
hit the local administration building in
freedom square no less in the centre of
the eastern city of kharkiv
homes regularly come under fire now too
this is an apartment building in the
black sea port city of hassan
and this kharkiv again
the russian liberators have come the man
shouts in the aftermath of tuesday's
missile strike
president vladimir zelensky addressing
the european union called it the price
of freedom this morning two cruise
missiles
hit this freedom square
dozens of killed
ones this is the price of freedom the
translator struggles to contain his
emotion
we are fighting
just for our
land
and for our freedom
seventy ukrainian soldiers died when a
military base was targeted by heavy
artillery in akhtirka
but the veil has fallen from russia's
claims that it's carrying out a special
operation aimed purely at military
targets civilians are increasingly fair
game
and as night fell kharkiv came under
heavy attack again
the change of tactics a possible
consequence of russia's slow-moving
advance on the ground satellite imagery
shows a column of artillery and armor
logistics and support units more than 60
kilometers long bearing down on the
capital kiev from the north
another is advancing from the south the
aim to encircle the capital intimidate
the civilian population and force the
surrender of ukraine's government
western intelligence points to poor
communications and frequent mechanical
breakdowns
there's a dogged ukrainian resistance as
well
captured russian soldiers are said to
have been told that they'd be welcomed
here as liberators
this is how people actually feel
[Applause]
at the heart of it all in the capital
kiev attacks have resumed including on
the main television transmitter cutting
public broadcasts
people already eking out in existence in
conditions of unimaginable stress know
that worse is to come
and the scramble to leave the city on
the few exit routes still available
is growing more desperate by the hour
fighting has not yet come to the western
city of ulviv
but they'll be ready for it if it does
civil defense units have formed all over
the country and basic training in
weapons handling is available for anyone
that wants it
they know the time may come when they'll
have to fight the russians themselves
for control of their streets
the government says it believes russia
is deliberately shelling cities
including residential areas and civilian
infrastructure the goal it says to
create mass panic and civilian
casualties but one thing you don't sense
here is panic instead the steely
determination of ukrainian civilians to
resist and fight back
we want to study we don't want to be
afraid
stop the word
the young in ukraine students
multicultural
multilingual joined the chorus for peace
bright minds whose ideals until a week
ago were still intact
whose hopes and hearts now are broken
stop the war stop your mouth jonah al
jazeera leave